is this part three of my visit to Sweden
to test the division to F massive
entertainment hell yes it is sorry I
have to keep repeating this the whole
thing was over so fast I need to remind
myself that it actually happened you see
I'm a dude that started making videos
and uploading them to YouTube for purely
selfish reasons one it's a creative
outlet for me and two it was my way of
showing friends in a more simplistic way
of how to play RPGs in particular the
division it was selfish because I really
just wanted them to keep playing the
game with me then something weird
happened other people started watching
my videos and saying lovely things the
next thing I know I'm on a flight to
Sweden anyway I'm getting a bit
distracted in this video I'll be talking
to you about the specializations in the
skills and the division - I'll be
keeping this pretty simple especially
since this portion wasn't the main
intention of our visit but given the
time frames I wouldn't expect too much
change from what we've seen here
[Music]
we had a few restrictions in place for
this testing the biggest one being time
but thankfully for me I was able to team
up with macro style in order to cover
more of the content so I'll flag this
one off right now please if for some
reason you've come across my video
before hers check out his channel for a
more in-depth analysis on what are we
covering here specializations on our
first run we were given high level
characters to play with
they were level 30 and we each had a
specialization equipped unfortunately we
weren't able to change these however
this is one of the reasons that Marco
and I swapped footage at the end of the
event he was running survivalist and I
had sharpshooter the other two guys were
using demolitionist we weren't really
able to navigate through the
specialization tree and even if we were
this is some of the menu footage that
I'm unable to show you at this stage so
everything I'll be talking about is from
a hands-on testing point of view but
also through Marco's footage and
feedback over the mic when it comes to
the specializations all we've really
been told us that they're replacing the
signature skills and that they will have
their own skill tree offering further
customization at built diversity we all
know about the signature weapons but
would not really seen much about how
these specializations differ from each
other I feel this information I'm about
to provide is really just the tip of the
iceberg and I expect to see a lot more
info once we can fully navigate the
skill trees sharpshooter equipped to the
50 caliber rifle one thing I can say
about this weapon is that it feels good
it's loud and it kicks back like an
absolute beast this really is a one shot
weapon which is fine because a heads
like a truck unfortunately I had a
little bit too much fun with this weapon
and wasted a lot of my rounds early on
expecting to find a lot more but I can
honestly say through the series of
failed shots that I had the weapon
certainly has its strengths and
weaknesses you won't be running around
firing this from the hip and you'll be
wanting to be in a fairly safe place
because the recoil are so strong that
disorientate you somewhat leaving you
open to attack something I noticed with
the specialization is that everything
felt a little bit more comfortable at
medium to long range distance and I'm
not just talking about 50 Cal because as
I said I wished most of these shots
early on it's more that it feels like
there are a number of passive bonuses
that provided extra stability or damage
or defense for example win and cover we
noticed these two small bars that show
up on the armor bar
it looks as though and overshield I
can't confirm this but again it does
show that there are some active buffs
being added to the class women cover and
if these are anything like traditional
skill trees within RPGs
there will be other branches that add
further bonuses to the style of play
something that's be mentioned before is
that there will be specific skills type
to each specialization the additional
sharpshooter skill was the tactician
drone the stone is one that hovers
around you scouting and marking nearby
enemies and the level of detail was
giving made it feel like an invaluable
skill to have in your team especially in
the darker areas of the map it's like a
pulse but it was constantly scanning for
new targets from what we were able to
play around with at the event the
specializations each seemed to have a
unique weapon a unique skill a unique
grenade and various unique passive perks
and bonuses that further influenced the
style of play intended for the specific
specialization survivalist as I said
before I didn't get a chance to play the
specialization this information is all
based off markers footage and feedback
while playing the crossbow looks
interesting to me but it seems a little
bit gimmicky it will be interesting to
see how the enemies react to it on the
first shot
like does it offer any sort of reduction
and NPC awareness when it comes to your
location there is a sort of fuse that
comes with the explosive tip it might be
useful as a crowd control weapon but the
delay does give the enemies a chance to
move out of the way the survivalists
unique skill is the Mandir seeker mind
the seeker mine rolls around between you
and your allies healing armor much like
the other healing related skills the
amount of healing it gives us pretty low
but to be fair we weren't able to miss
around the builds too much so our skill
power was pretty rubbish so depending on
what sort of buffs you can add to it it
could be pretty handy skill to have
while running in a group one thing we
noticed straight away was that the med
kits worked quite different between the
specializations with sharpshooter using
a mid kit would give you a full health
boost putting the remainder into armor
so if you were at half health
you'd get half your armor back too with
survivalist the med kit ignores health
and goes straight into healing armor
over time this is quite a fast overtime
heal and while the med kit is heal and
you seem to be able to negate a little
bit of extra damage at this stage I can
see this becoming preference for most
players the unique grenade is a
fragmentation grenade
it's basically let the standard
concussion grenade except with a larger
explosion radius and the
to cause bleep to the targets skills
there are eight skill types each with a
number of mods two of them were locked
off to us during this event the Kim
launcher and something called
Firefly pulse there are three different
pulse mods Jemma
scanner and remote the jammer pulse
works very similar to the disabling
pulse we used to win seeing hunters when
they first appear but without the crazy
range the scanner pulse works much the
same as the one we used to in the
Division one it highlights enemies on
the map the remote pulse seems quite
similar to the scanner pulse except that
you place this one on the ground and it
continually pulses around it turret
there are two different turret mods both
of which we've seen in the division one
the incinerator turret and the assault
tart the assault turret tracks and
attacks enemies the only thing different
here is that you can now manually target
up to specific enemies the incinerator
turret will flame tart has made a
comeback but this time it's much
different rather than throwing it out
and letting it do its thing we now need
to place it down and direct it we want
the arc of flame to be directed this
will now be considerably more
situational probably best to watch a
doorway or any small area where enemies
are funneled through hive the hive kind
of X like a support station and division
two there are three standard mods
restorer wasp and booster restore is
your classic healing station from what
can be noticed in game this here was
slow but again it must be noticed that
we couldn't play with the builds too
much so being more sticked into skill
power could change this considerably
throwing at a wasp I it would have a
number of micro drones released and
attacking the nearest enemy I don't know
why but a family is quite fun not sure
of the damage potential but they
certainly distract the enemies for a
while
booster - this delivers a stimulant to
increase movement skill haste and wit
and handling again this will come down
to what happens when more skill powers
throw an edit it didn't experience any
noticeable boost at the event well not
enough to use it over one of the other
skills seeker mine carried over from the
division one there are two standard mode
options in the division - air burst and
explosive these both work in much the
same way except now you need to target
we'd like them to go you can't just
quickly use them on the fly drone sort
of like a flying turret these come in
two types defender and striker
the defender drone can be targeted onto
yourself or an ally its job to deflect
incoming bullets
it feels pretty minimal what it's able
to stop at the stage but again it might
be better with higher skill powers and
mods the Stryker drone is like a flying
assault turret the damage seems pretty
low which makes sense as it's just
continuously firing the entire time it's
out great for distracting NPCs from a
PvP point of view these were the most
annoying thing to deal with
they'll constantly getting behind you
while you're in cover and it didn't feel
like though that easy to take down
shield the ballistic shield is also
making a return this time it comes in
two types Crusader and bulwark the
Crusader shield is a lightweight shield
that allows the user to have any primary
weapon equipped while using it though it
doesn't take long to break it and it
doesn't protect your legs
I found this pretty decent of PvP when
trying to push forward and get people
out of cover but only for short bursts
you can't just stand out in the open and
tank the day so that you can now the
bulwark shield is the traditional shield
that we used to full body cover high
defence but you can only use the sidearm
while it's out so this was just a
rundown of what we were able to test at
the event as I said on a number of
occasions depending on the sort of hard
caps a lot of these skills however
really could make or break the situation
that they'd be useful I still have hours
of footage from the event that I haven't
shown in this past few videos so had a
few more videos coming up soon at this
stage you've probably seen a number of
videos from other players who have flown
out to Red Storm and massive so what do
you think so far are you looking forward
to the division 2 after this hands-on
experience from so much more hype for
the game than it was before I had so
many concerns around the game being
oversimplified we're just generally
losing the feel of the game that have
been enjoying for the last few years but
this certainly wasn't the case if you
love the division 1 you won't be
disappointed do I think it would be
completely void of bugs and balancing
issues from day one god no these games
are far too complicated to expect there
in order to achieve true balance within
the game you need to remove all build
diversity and in doing that it would no
longer be the division I'm expecting
some teething issues for sure but for
now I need to make sure I have all of
these shields completed I want my damn
backpack teddy bear Cheers
Oh
detecting additional hostile contacts
you